sup doggies ll cool mike here with the
newest hip-hop single from tom mcdonald
you know tom mcdonald is a rapper a
musician who
has a not very woke message who
contradicts the left-wing orthodoxy
which is why he's become extremely
successful and everyone downloads his
songs so he's got a new song out i have
not listened to it yet i want to give
you my absolutely unvarnished opinion
[ __ ] a love for safety mother first
thing i notice when i pull up this video
by tom it's it's called the new world
order right it refers to a phrase used
by george h.w bush
bringing in a new world order the phrase
has been used in many other contexts the
new
world order of wrestling brother but it
got got new life over the past 30 years
when george bush senior used it in a a
major speech which is now hard to find
on youtube actually so when you look up
the new world order tom mcdonald
on youtube it says context new world
order wikipedia
the new world order is a conspiracy
theory which hypothesizes a secretly
emerging totalitarian world government
it's a conspiracy theory
it's totally don't believe anything
something tells me
that it's
this warning is probably proving the
point that tom has made in a lot of one
of his other videos
first of course this video is sponsored
by naturally it's clean naturally it's
clean is dedicated to providing
effective cleaning products using
powerful plant-based enzymes more from
them later first
let's hear from tom
here's the problem with america the
country is broken because they might
stay closed but they might stay open get
attacked and we blend terrorists go
broke and we blame the price blame
racist for the racism but only if his
skin is white if we don't need guns
because we can call the police
even just that first line he tom is
really good in that he fits a lot of
different ideas it like line by line by
line he packs a lot of stuff in so i
love this line
the
the problem is that our minds stay
closed but our mouths stay open this is
also very good advice to anyone who's in
a meeting who's getting involved in
public life
generally it is better to be quiet and
thought an idiot than to open your mouth
and prove it true international
depression i'm not saying there's no
role for speaking i like to think that
there's some role for speaking since i
do it for a living but the hope is that
you're reading much more than you're
speaking that you're thinking much more
than you're speaking that you're taking
in lots of ideas and what tom is saying
is all people are doing these days is
blah blah blah blah blah but they
actually haven't thought through any of
these issues all right keep going time
the price blame racist for the racism
but only if his skin is white if we
don't need guns because we only blame
the white guys that's true that's what
happens call a fireman please you didn't
want to build a wall and now the border
is weak your favorite actor has a gate
that's like 15 feet racism is gay if
you're offended that's [ __ ]
intolerance is great until you speak and
you're a target
racism is gay and if you're offended
you're [ __ ] that is poetry just
below the level of john keats but far
better than many modern poets racism is
gay and if you're offended you're
[ __ ]
it actually takes a lot of perception
and talent to write that line keep going
intolerance is great until you speak and
you're a target if a white man paints
his face black he's a racist piece of
garbage but you put him in a dress and
he's courageous and he's gorgeous all
these double standards man i'm tired of
the noise freedom's an illusion if they
censor your voice call a dad a deadbeat
for neglecting his boys but a mom kills
a baby and you call it pro-choice whoa
he went there pause it he totally went
there man that's this is something even
a lot of the pro-life movement won't
touch
the pro-life movement
i think for tactical reasons really just
focuses on the abortionists focuses on
deadbeat dads who run away
focuses on a lack of community support
for women
but
all of that is important obviously women
are
who find themselves in these difficult
situations have a pressure on them that
other people do not that's that's one of
the central issues to work
work out that the pro-life movement is
trying to answer to the pro-abortion
people who say just kill the kid but
what tom is saying here is we've got to
focus on the reality here okay yeah
deadbeat dads are a problem i think we
should basically throw them in jail or
just force them to get married and make
it much harder to get divorced
or force them to pay a lot of money in
child support starting with conception
or would it focus on society or this or
that but we also need to focus on the
reality here of a baby
of human life
beyond even the the pro-life issue
you've gotta you've gotta have fairness
here he's pointing out
anything a white guy does is racist
anything a black guy does is not racist
even if the white guy is wonderful and
charitable and doesn't judge anyone on
the color of their skin and even if the
black guy hates all the white people how
dare you it's a ridiculous double
standard we can't live in a society like
that when you bring a product into your
home you want to be sure your
hard-earned money is going to a brand
that believes in the same stuff that you
believe in personal responsibility
community environmental responsibility
and your freedom and your way of life
which is why i'm so excited to share
with you a brand that i love they not
only have tremendous cleaning products
best i've ever used but they also have
the same values that we do naturally
it's clean is that brand it's a great
partner of the daily wire naturally it's
clean is a home cleaning company
dedicated to providing effective
cleaning products using powerful
plant-based enzymes they have
specialized formulas for every area of
the home from the kitchen to the
bathroom to the laundry room they have
you covered with hospital grade
plant-based enzyme solutions everything
manufactured right here in the u.s of a
they offer a free two-day shipping
direct to your door i would recommend
starting with a daily wire four pack of
the essentials which include four great
products simply visit
naturallyitsclean.com michael use promo
code michael to receive 15 off your
order cleaning products are expensive if
you can keep a home clean
then you will want to make sure that you
stock up because you're going to go
through them really really fast we
encourage our listeners not only to keep
your home clean but to support companies
like natural aids clean while you do it
because they support your conservative
values check them out today get the
daily wire essentials kit go to
naturallyitsclean.com michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
responsibility that's what tom is saying
here on race on life on society he's
saying
don't just blame one group and say the
other group is totally scot-free there's
a lot of blame there's a lot of
brokenness to go around before you
accuse me take a look at yourself before
you fix your neighbor pull out the plank
out of your own i keep going tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
don't do that in front of me imma let
off around pal scream loud burn the city
down now put it on the news make em all
feel proud look make a system where 85
percent of black people fill the prison
is it cause they black or they make bad
decisions i ain't good at math but it
seems like it's division or is it white
privilege i believe politicians need to
be locked up try to take our freedoms
that's how you get shot up gotta back
against the wall try to just stop us
more guns more ammunition please stock
up election gets rigged rights get
infringed take this syringe frighten
your kids show up right where you live
make me wanna grab a rifle and just go
you act like you're so much better than
us yeah we
[Music]
there before he gets into this next
verse i really like what he's doing here
which is he is still manning
right wing
arguments or talking points or no it's
not even really arguments it's more just
sentiments
gosh why is that this is all so unfair
there's this insane racial narrative
that's being pushed under this insane
sexual narrative you've got fouchies of
the world trying to squirt us full of
this experimental drug even if we're not
at a huge risk from the virus it makes
me so mad it makes me so mad i want to
do something bad hey
right so it's not just the
right wing guy is totally wonderful and
pristine and saintly
he is impelled to do something bad he
says i want to go shoot somebody i want
to stock up on bullets but i've got all
these
legitimate sentiments
that real that real feeling that real
reaction can spur you to do something
that would be wrong that would be evil
that's a much more complicated picture
than just
right wing guy good left wing guy bad or
vice versa right wing guy bad left wing
guy good okay keep going
and everyone blames white folks for
every little bitty thing we don't have
no one to blame we take responsibility
they tell you be a man then call it
toxic masculinity that when you act
through feminine they call it white
fragility i don't understand trans man
with humility i'm just trying to raise
my kid the best of my ability if i
disagree you try to cancel get rid of me
you cancer you can't be the answer
you're killing me
there's no way out so he's saying look i
get it the way the society works the
only group the only racial group that
you can attack are
white people
that this is you can discriminate
against white people and asians to a
lesser degree in college admissions but
even beyond that it's the only group
that you can socially insult and
castigate say white people are the worst
race in the history of the world same
thing with men you can really go after
men you certainly can't go after women
or other sort of sexually confused
people who maybe they are men but they
think they're women or vice versa that
that is off limits and so he says okay
whatever i accept that
but then you're telling me
that i need to talk about my feelings
because i'm so toxic so then i talk
about my feelings and you say that i'm
fragile so you're telling me you're
saying please come on cry real men cry
and then the minute i cry you say stop
being a whiny little wimp stop stop
pretending that you have real problems
well then i can't do anything
you don't want me to what do you want me
to do you're telling me anything i do is
damned if i do and i'm damned if i don't
answer you killing me i hate white
supremacy just as much as you but i
ain't feeling guilty for something i
didn't do the system's killing everyone
it sucks but it's true they kill you
then they broadcast it and call it the
news or the brain wash you through
social media feeds and if you disagree
delete you immediately make america
china pretty easy to see i will always
remember the land of the free
you act like you're so much better than
that us told you that you so special
to a new world order your facts ain't
facts without censoring us yeah we know
that good job you lose is your medal
to
[Music]
i love it this might be my favorite one
yet
i'm not the
top hip-hop aficionado despite my uh
frequent uh analysis of these songs but
i really like the announce it's it's
much more complex than you would expect
a song like this to be you would expect
the song to be the liberal establishment
bad
all the rest of us good but what what
tom is
saying here is no we're actually
we're doing some bad things we have some
bad reactions we're kind of being
impelled to that yeah there's maybe a
system that is encouraging that and
there's really no way out but really
there is no way out i actually am in
this straight jacket there's no simple
answer where i can just break out the
window and climb out or something
this is an actual structural
political problem
and it's a lot deeper than race and it's
a lot deeper than sex and it's a lot
deeper than any one issue
good stuff
[Music]
[Music]
you